good good alright hello everybody and
thank you for sticking around I know
it's been a really long conference but
you could just like had your brains
crammed full of awesome stats and
probabilistic goodness and we are hoping
to continue that now and my name is
Mitzi Morris I'm a member of the stand
development team I work up at Columbia
with Andrew Gelman and I am going to
talk about Bayesian inference for you
with you to you and so let's get some
general remarks in review and what we're
going to talk about is multilevel
regression models in stan and then ways
to evaluate inference so Stan how many
of you are using Stan okay good
how many of you would like to use Stan
how many of you have heard of sted great
okay this is better um great so stan is
named after Stanislaw ulam who
originated Monte Carlo estimation so
we'll start with the story and the story
is how Stanislaw ulam came up with the
Monte Carlo estimation technique which
is that he was working at los alamos on
the Manhattan Project and he got sick so
they sent him to the hospital and in
those days if you're in the hospital and
you're working on a super highly
classified top-secret project you do not
get to bpn back to the lab so he had
nothing to do in his hotel room but play
solitaire and as a statistician he
looked at solitaire the game and said
well what are my chances if I have a
perfectly shuffled deck of cards and I
deal myself out the solitaire game what
are my chances of winning
um and so from probability theory you
should be able to start having 50 to
choose 151 choose 2 bla bla bla for all
of your stuff and he realized that he
just couldn't figure out what that big
combinatorics was and this was
distressing because he thought he should
be able to do it and in the end he just
played games of solitaire over and over
and over again and counted up the number
that he won and the number that he lost
and at the end he had an estimate of his
chances of winning any random game of
solitaire from a well shuffled deck and
so that is essentially estimation by
simulation you simulate a whole bunch of
times and that set of simulations are
your sample and at the end you look at
your sample and you compute over the
sample and answer the questions that you
want to answer using the proportional
information that's present in your
sample ok so that's that's it that's
Monte Carlo methods and they're called
Monte Carlo methods because there's a
famous casino in Monte Carlo where you
go gambling and so everything there is
random so it's all about randomness Stan
is a probabilistic programming language
so it's a domain-specific programming
language and what you are doing in the
Stan language when you write a Stan
program is you are expressing the total
joint probability of all the parameters
in your model so we're going to get to
that and we'll see lots of examples Stan
uses the Stan nuts HMC sampler which
does Monte Carlo Markov chain Monte
Carlo sampling and this is what sort of
took Stan and they were original there
were already probabilistic programming
languages using Bayesian techniques bugs
and Jags Stan is an order of magnitude
more powerful
then they are precisely because the
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo that's the HMC
in HMC Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is a very
efficient way of doing this simulation
these random jumps around posterior
probability density and it works really
well when you're in super-high
dimensions and by super-high dimensions
I mean you no more than three or four
more than ten definitely more than ten
but think about what you're doing in any
given day when you're trying to answer
some kind of questions about your data
you're usually trying to get all these
features and if you're doing something
like natural language the amount of
features you have are very very very big
even if you're just collecting
information about your population about
your users you've probably got a dozen
features a hundred features that's a
very high dimensional space each feature
is adding a dimension and these make
things very challenging usually there's
a lot of correlations between different
features in your data and this is going
to be difficult to compute so the Stan
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo method does a
very efficient job of giving you a
representative sample from your
complicated posterior space complicated
geometry space of the probability of all
of your parameters so and Stan has been
around for about six or seven years now
and almost all of the people who were
originally using Stan were people who
are working in are so the our ecosystem
for Stan is very very rich and I started
working on a Python interface to Stan in
January of this year which were calling
commands
pi and because i think that you know
people in the Python community should be
using Stan and should be doing Bayesian
data analysis and actually I don't care
if you use Stan but I do want you to use
Bayesian data analysis and Stan is open
source and command Stan PI is BSD
licensed and what we're talking about
today is multi-level modeling it's a
kind of regression modeling it's what
you want to do and as Kim was talking
about there's this notion of pooling
we're going to see exactly how pooling
works and what we mean by pooling
information and there are a lot of names
for these so and there's also a blog
statistical modeling causal inference
and social science and Bob carpenter put
up a post one day about all the names
for hierarchical and multi-level
modeling and it's a really nice post
because he gives you insight on all
these names just exactly what that group
of people meant when they decided to
build their multi-level model and why
they called it named it the way they did
and how it differs from everybody else
so what you find in the domain of
science is that every group was trying
to solve a problem they they consulted
their statistician they came up with
really really really great techniques
that are pretty much the same thing as
what they came up with the lab down the
hall and they all published and they all
published independently so pretty much
every model that you want to use for
your data has been developed by somebody
else for their data and it's just the
challenge of finding them and
communicating is really difficult and
that's what makes working on stands so
much fun because our user base spans the
gamut of every single kind of user
anybody who's got data is talking to
each other on the forums and we're all
learning from each other
statistical inference we learn about
unknown or unobserved quantities of a
process from the data generated by that
quantum process so what we're doing in
contrast to machine learning especially
those of you who are like gotta do some
got to do some deep belief and that's
got to do some deep learning that's a
really really really great and there are
many many many cases where that's really
the best thing you can do and you should
go ahead and do it
but there are also cases where you're
not going to be able to make that fly in
which case you would be well-served by
looking into stan and what we're doing
when we're doing Bayesian modeling is
we're trying to do a kind of a white box
model we care about your data generating
process and what we're going to do with
your generated data is we're going to
try to build a model and work backwards
from the data to find out more about
your model especially when the
parameters in your model are actionable
items so that's really for a policymaker
or for a business decision maker or for
a scientist you care about what those
parameters are because those are the
things you can change and so by having a
model where all the parameters are
clearly labeled they're giving you a
bunch of levers a bunch of dials on your
process and you can tune them and tweak
them and then ask yourself what's going
to happen and that's generally what
people want to do so that's why Bayesian
methods and Bayesian models are really
really the way to go and the Bayesian
workflow is one where you spend some
time thinking about the model thinking
about the data generating process and
you don't need to worry that much about
your distributions or your math you're
asking yourself you know what are the
dependencies how are things related to
each other and as
especially for multi-level models we
want to know what things are nested
inside of each other is there
interesting structure in the data that's
coming in that should be reflected in
the model that you're developing once
you've got your model then you're going
to use a tool like Stan to do the
estimation that's just that's just you
know taking some something down off the
shelf and running your data through it
to get an answer what you care about is
afterwards you don't just take that
answer and run you you sit back and you
look at that answer and you interrogate
that answer and you say hey wait is this
really what I expect given what I know
about the world because the other thing
that Bayesian this like historical
Bayesian frequentist debate is all about
not using not putting your thumb on the
scale right Bayesian czar putting their
thumb on the scale well okay so what
it's not like everybody let me let me
let me let me try to make that sound
less defensive we're using what we know
about the world and no matter how you
build your model you're cooking in what
you know your cooking your expectations
into your model so we're being honest
and we're thinking very hard about what
we know and we're going to ask ourselves
is this what I expect given what I know
at every step of the way and that's
really all that's going on and what we
want to do with this Bayesian workflow
and what the people who've worked on
Stan the set of tools especially this
downstream ecosystem of visualization
and model checking are trying to do is
we're we're encouraging you to develop
as many variants of a model as you need
to give yourself the answers of what's
the minimum I can get away with
what's the maximum I should be doing
playing around with what you know about
the problem you're trying to solve so
it's we're really trying to facilitate
engagement with the question that you're
trying to answer more than anything else
statistical notation just so we can be
clear and you've seen this a bunch today
right
nothing scary on this slide great then
we'll just go on Bayes theorem
have we seen Bayes theorem tonight
everybody happy with Bayes theorem okay
so let's go over this slide what we're
interested in is we've got the
conditional probability and for Bayesian
the important the important thing that
we're working with is the posterior
probability distribution we've collected
our data we've built our model we've run
our data through our inference engine
what we have at the end is we have a
posterior probability distribution and
that's what we want to work with so in
the slide what's most important is to
notice there is to notice that in this
probability of theta given Y it's the
probability of your parameters given
your data and I started doing statistics
about a dozen years ago and I kept
driving my husband crazy because I would
just you know write down probability of
Y given theta and probability of the
data given Y and my husband's Bob
carpenter
because he developed Stan originally and
he'd be like you can't you mean what
it's confusing okay it really matters it
took me a while to master this so it's
okay if it takes you guys a while to
master this too but we care about the
posterior probability distribution hello
my little thingy here and when we build
a stand model
the Stan is computing is it's computing
the total joint probability density of
all of your parameters and your data all
at once and it's really cool that it's
doing this and when you are writing your
model you are supplying the priors on
your parameters and you are coming up
with your likelihood function this is
what you supply to your stand model when
you develop a stand model or any
Bayesian model and this is what you get
and it's really nice that you've got
this proportional constant because that
makes things go a lot faster any
questions on this one no and the reason
that we want to be Bayesian is that we
want to be able to actually think about
our posterior distribution the
probability of theta given why we want
to think about it as a full probability
distribution so we can get the mean
median mode and crucially the standard
deviation which is what gives us our
uncertainty and there was a woman here
who asked a question about credible
intervals if you're doing Bayesian data
analysis the credible intervals are
whatever boundaries you want to put on
your posterior probability distribution
so you can have the 95% central
confidence interval you can which is two
standard deviations from the mean and
when you have a full credible interval
you can look at the quantiles in that
credible interval you can figure out
whether or not you've got a really
sharply peaked posterior probability
distribution meaning yeah almost all the
time
I know that all my data is going to be
here and it's going to look just like
that or you can have a very very
broad shallow sort of a posterior
probability distribution which means you
know I'm not so sure about what I know I
know that it could be you know between 2
and 98 but gosh I really don't know much
more than that and that's really useful
information for you to proceed in any
kind of a decision-making situation so
Monte Carlo simulation what do we mean
by a sample I think what we mean by a
sample is that we've got somewhere in
our back pocket we've got a random
number generator and we're going to be
able to generate quantities random
quantities at will and a classic example
of Monte Carlo simulation is calculating
PI it works really nicely because you
can take you a random number generator
and you can generate numbers between
minus 1 and 1 really easily and if you
do that for X Y points you've now got a
rectangle which has an area of 4 and you
have a unit circle and the area of your
unit circle is PI R squared and then
with just a little bit of algebra you
can count all of the points with a
simple mathematical formula is x squared
plus y squared less than one grade there
in the circle otherwise they're out of
the circle how many what's the
proportion of points in the circle pi is
your answer we're multiplying it by 4
and so you can do that in Python and I
did that in Python and I did that in
Python a hundred times and my estimate
of Pi was 3.5 which is kind of a
ballpark estimate and then I did it a
little bit longer and I started to get
pretty pretty close you know as much as
I needed to know about pi and it took
more and more time and the point of this
slide is that when you
using these estimation by simulation
techniques you need a sample and you
only need as big a sample as you need to
get the precision the accuracy that
matters to you so if you don't have a
need for five decimal places of accuracy
you don't have to go there because it'll
take a long time the Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo I said a little bit about
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo I can't say
anything more about Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo and get there in this but if
you're interested I love this paper it's
a really nice and there's a link at the
end of my slides I put a link to this
paper it's a really nice example of how
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo works and it
compares it to Gibbs samplers which some
of which some of you might have heard of
and shows why you really really really
want to be using Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
and there are as I mentioned PI MC three
Edward and pyro are all using
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo so I'm not here
to tell you you have to use Stan I'm
just here to tell you you should let's
go on to linear regression linear
regression is everybody know linear
regression good so we've here's here's
your canonical example you've got just a
simple pair of XY predictors X is your
data why is your observed outcome you
want to create a model of the data
generating process for Y and you're just
going to put weights on your X's so
you're going to figure out where's your
intercept and what is the slope of the
line and now you can draw a line through
your cloud of points that minimizes the
distance from every Y to its Y on the
line so it's a vertical distance and it
works out really nicely in terms of the
US
and when you have a regression model you
are saying that my regression model is
going to fit my data with some amount of
random error and that epsilon is
considered to be random noise
independent random noise so epsilon has
the distribution of normal centered zero
with some unknown variance Sigma that
means that we plug X in as the estimate
of our mean and we use Sigma as our
variance and there we have it a Stan
programs statement which says that our
observed data Y is drawn from a normal
distribution with mean alpha plus beta
times X and variance Sigma so this is
your first example of Stan syntax any
instance int X was developed to look
like bugs syntax or our syntax and I
think there are things in Python where
you might be using this sampling
notation so our first example is Major
League Player batting ability there's a
very detailed case study I generated the
PDF from the case study and it ran 260
pages it's a great case study and my
goal today is to get you through the
highlights of this so that you can then
dive in and appreciate the goodness in
this case study and we're looking at
baseball players
I mean statistics and baseball are just
like you know beans and cornbread what
we've got here are data for Major League
Baseball players this is based on a
study case study that was done by
somebody named Brad Efron bootstrap Brad
if you've used the bootstrap technique
Efrain and Morris and he's not related
to me but you know
it's too bad and what they did was they
looked at the 1975 major league baseball
season cherry picked a couple of
interesting cases of you know good
players and not-so-good players and they
looked at their first 45 at-bats and
then they had the stats on the rest of
the season and there are three ways that
we can look at deciding what the
predictions we should make about the
number of hits that a player gets in a
certain number of at-bats we can say
that all players are exactly alike and
so all we need to do is estimate average
player ability we can say that all
players are snowflakes they're very
special and each player gets his own
model which you guys might be doing in
some of your applications right you're
every stock has its own model or
something or you can try to do the multi
level thing which is what everybody
really really wants to do which is to
say that ok we have a general population
of baseball players if you're a major
league baseball player you probably fit
this profile and we know something in
general about what our major league
baseball players look like and we know
that players differ from Player to
Player so we have what are the group
level effects and the individual or a
random effects and so that's what our
our multi-level model is going to do for
you and then we're going to show you
what the results of setting up these 3
models look like so to model player
batting ability we're using a binomial
distribution that is to say we have a
number of at-bats and during that number
of at-bats our player got a certain
number of hits so that is the
distribution on the bottom hello laser
pointer so we're going to calculate the
probability of say getting 18 hits
in your first 45 at-bats given that you
have an ability theta and this theta is
comes from your Bernoulli from your coin
flip model you've got a binary out huh
come you get up to bat you get a hit or
you don't get a hit here are our players
these are the top players and the bottom
players in this 18 player example
dataset Roberto Clemente in his first 45
at-bats in the 1975 Major League
Baseball season got 18 hits which would
give him a batting average of 400 are
there any baseball fans here okay so
what major league baseball player ever
got had a 400 average Ted Williams yes
you get asked in that one yes so we
don't really I mean Roberto Clemente
don't get me wrong he's great but do we
really think that he had a 400 batting
average I don't know about it and this
leads to the next question is why did
they use 45 at-bats well he probably
didn't get a hit on they at bat number
46 or at bat number 47 because then they
would have gone up to 50 you know so
when you get your data you should
interrogate your data from the get-go in
any case this is the example we're
working with and if we plot so this plot
is showing you the individual batting
averages and the average batting
averages so these are your two choices
for models number one and models number
two and this is a little bit more a
quick review of the binomial
distribution what's cool about the
binomial distribution is it is giving
you a integer value output so this is
for this distribution we don't have any
information there is no getting a hit
14.5 right either you're going to get
14 hits you can get 15 hits and if you
had a 400 batting average you in 45
at-bats might only get 11 or 12 that is
within the the credible interval and you
might you might get 24 and when you
think about this you begin to understand
when you're watching the World Series
and every time a player did it got a
really good hit yeah I got lucky really
it's pretty random so yeah and what
we're going to do is we're going to show
you some steam models and I'm gonna try
to go as quickly as I can through stand
because I don't want to get bogged down
in teaching you how to write Stan
programs because it's learning another
programming language but I will say that
Stan as a programming language has a
syntax which is not pythonic sorry your
variables are strongly typed your blocks
are enclosed by curly braces you have
orderid blocks and the named blocks are
calling out the important parts of your
Stan program this is a really really
cool feature of Stan but it's a good
thing and a bad thing
it does make you think about what is my
data and what are my parameters at the
same time when you're writing your Stan
model it doesn't always make it that
easy to see the data generating process
story told that cleanly and so there's a
lot of talk in the student community
about how we're going to change the Stan
language and possibly make Stan programs
different to write so another reason for
not going into stand right now and
that's pretty much all you need to know
about Stan syntax and again in a Stan
program you declare all of your
parameters in a special named parameters
block and then in the model block the
model block is where the Stan program
computes the joint log probability
density of the parameters
and the data so the model blocks special
parameters blocks special data block
also special here is a multi-level model
in Stan it's taken directly from the
case study so we have a parameter Phi
which is the population chance of
success so that looks like our Bernoulli
Phi if you compare it to here in the all
players are all alike we call that Phi
that's your average player ability and
for all different players we have a
vector of parameters theta so here in
the multi-level model we have this Phi
and we have this theta and we have a
Kappa which is prior on our prior and
the case study goes into why this
particular parameterisation was chosen
and it's very interesting to follow
because there are some difficulties with
this parameterization this is not that
easy to fit and you could make your
model more efficient by Reaper ammeter
izing which is again a very important
part of building model that you're going
to drop into a production workflow it's
got to compute in real time so in this
model here we put we put a hyper prior
on our prior and then we compute our
prior and our likelihood know if this is
our likelihood this is our prior this is
a hyper prior okay what I said and so
when we fit this model we see that the
orange is the outcome of using the
multi-level model and what
does is it smooth out our estimates it
lets us say that the best players are
better than the worst players or
not-so-hot players but they're more
alike than we thought they were so in
this visualization the very last bar
here on the right is the complete
pooling model so it's not really a
player but I put it in that way instead
of drawing the average line across okay
would you like to see how this works or
should I go on to the next soccer model
let's see how it works so I've put the I
put the links to these notebooks and all
of this data up on the stand website and
I post it in the select general select
channel so you can download these slides
and and this data set this is the data
set and here's the link to the case
study for you so we're going to use
command stand PI which is a lightweight
wrapper around commenced in which is the
command line interface to the stand
inference engine so we'll just make sure
that we're using Stan and oh look we're
using the very latest commune Stan 2:21
here are our baseball players and yep
that's the data and then we're going to
plot
yeah and this is just the plot that I
created to show you so this is using oh
no it this is just plotting the data
right right right right so what we have
to do for command Stan pie is we're
going to munch out the data that we want
to feed into our model we're just
munching the data here so we're going to
feed in a data dictionary and what's
going to be in that data dictionary are
the the names of all the variables that
are in the data block of the model and
just for fun this is how I computed the
binomial distribution which was in that
the plot we looked at that's not really
very interesting for what we're doing
now so now we're actually going to go
through command Stan and we are going to
we first we're going to declare our
model and once we've declared the model
it's a it's a disk it's it's a file on
disk we can examine what that is so
we'll print out the code for the model
then we're going to compile the model
and then we're going to do the fit and
then we're going to get the summary of
how well the model fits the data
okay so bombs away
and you can see that it is right now
compiling the model while we admire the
model and it's going to take about 30
seconds well it took much longer to
compile that model than it did to run
for chains
so sampler chains are we familiar with
sampler chains okay we're doing Markov
chain Monte Carlo so what command Stan
PI is doing is it's firing off for
parallel processes where the stand model
is starting and it's taking the data and
it's doing this mark
chain Monte Carlo so that's a chain and
it's giving you a sample so the reason
we want to run multiple chains in
parallel is not that we care about
whether or not they're parallel but when
we're done we want to compare all the
chains against each other because we've
got this Hamiltonian that's jumping
around in this complicated posterior
space and if you have coated your model
and made a mistake somewhere along the
way or if you just have the wrong model
or if you've just really done something
super stupid your sampler will get stuck
so what you want to see if you've got a
good if you've got a model that is well
conditioned appropriate for your data
you want to be able to know that
whenever you fired up a chain that
you've got this nice super random
behavior and so you're going to compare
a bunch of chains against each other and
you're going to look for the absence of
any patterns whatsoever
within chains or across chains and if
you get that behavior then you feel like
okay I've got the proper conditions for
me to reason about this sample the
sample truly is a random sample it's
generated from a process it's a Ghatak
it's reversible it is all these good
things I actually can trust that I've
now got a proper sample from my
posterior distribution because if you
don't have if you don't if your model
hasn't converged and you got a sample
you've got a sample from crap it doesn't
mean anything you cannot use this data
so we like this data because this
actually is correct and then we've got
all these drawers we've actually got
four thousand drawers in our sample from
the posterior now we can compute
statistics over them and we see what's
most important here is that we have Phi
is 270 0.27 so we're saying that your
your average baseball player has a 270
average find works that's pretty good
and now we're going to do exactly the
same thing just to show you that we can
do it twice and this is the second model
again it's taking a little bit of time
to compile and in this model we're just
going to yep there goes and now what
we've got is we've got estimates for
every player so player number one is
Roberto Clemente in the data we saw that
he had 400 batting average we've been
doing a taking a random sample and in
our random sample we said well really
the 50 percent quantile is at 400 and
for some reason it's telling me the mean
is at 4.40 one but that's because I
rounded to two places so they're
probably much closer critically what you
really want to know is dude my model
converge this is the R hat statistic
which is making sure that all your
chains have mixed and are perfectly
random yep my model converged our hat
has to be one or 1.0 if it's one point
one no good and what we see is we have
the number of effective samples in our
sample oh no this is the number of
effective samples per second this is how
fast how efficient our computation is
this is the number of effective samples
which is pretty cool because we ran
4,000 draws but there was anti
correlation so our sample actually is
giving us information more information
than than we thought we could squeeze
out of 4,000 draws we're actually
getting the equivalent of 10,000 draws
from from the posterior which is really
cool
and finally we get the the model here
the simple hierarchical model which is a
little bit more complicated in terms of
the amount of code like it's got like
six more lines of code and it takes the
same amount of time to compile and it
fits beautifully and now we've got
estimates for for our group level
predictor 270 is our average major
league baseball players batting ability
we've got this campus score that's the
hyper Pryor and we've got theta for
Roberto Clemente and we think Roberto
Clemente has actually got about in 320
batting average given what we've seen
and what we know which is still like
really super good and so as I said this
model was difficult to fit what you
might notice here is that I added this
parameter adapt Delta to my sampling
statement that meant go a little slower
take a little bit more time because we
know this model is is not going to do
the right thing and here if I say
diagnosed I get these Diagnostics and
Wow
yeah see still mmm not good we got some
we got some divergences so maybe I
should actually up the adapt Delta you
should actually read the case study to
go deeper into the problems with this
model and finally we do some
visualization and voila that's it okay
questions yeah and while we're doing
questions it's been a really long day so
I brought a chocolate for all of you in
case here
[Music]
well that's what hierarchical models are
can you pass this around and open I mean
over fitting well the the regularization
is the same thing as as putting a group
level effect on your data and you can
over fit this model I don't think is
over fitting the data because it's it's
pretty I mean over fitting the data
would mean that we would like crank up
the priors so that we would start in the
right place you can always build a model
to overfit your data yes
this model is pretty general but if you
don't have enough data then maybe you
shouldn't you know really consider these
parameters to be what you want to reason
with does ends your question
yeah well that that's the that gets back
to the whole Bayesian workflow but I
mean oops that gets back to the whole
Bayesian workflow when you're you're
interrogating your fit afterwards you do
want to know how sensitive are you to
outliers so you would take your fitted
model and this is where replication
comes in so we're going to see that in
the next example so just keep that
question in the back of your mind okay
yes yes yeah sure yes
well canon now I don't know about that
oh what a great question Kristine has
Auto diff stands auto-da-fé libraries
built in C++ so Stan implemented its own
auto def library and it is really
seriously fast so Kim was talking about
Auto grad the thing of it is is that
when you're setting up that automatic
differentiation how you how you evaluate
you are how you evaluate those functions
how you set up the calculation of the
gradient you should do it in a super
smart way so you should figure out which
steps are going to be computed over and
over again and how you make sure that
everything is memory local and you do it
out the wazoo so Stan is built on a very
high performance C++ automatic
differentiation library and Stan was
built to be fast because Andrew Gelman
is sitting there at every meeting and
all he says is I want my models to fit
faster
okay so so we've got people who really
care and they're our boss answer your
question great okay
yes I was actually gonna make you guys
are we okay cuz otherwise I'm gonna make
you get up and do jumping jacks cuz it's
been a long day but you seem to be okay
so that is baseball and the second
example is just it's another example of
setting up a model and looking at the
data and it's the Women's World Cup so
Nietzsche here is like thank her for
this model because she worked through it
and I worked with her and it's really um
it was a total blast we did this with
the pie ladies why did that say that
anyway okay that was in the wrong place
this is paired comparison so now we're
no longer talking about individual
baseball players we're talking about
teams and you want to know which team is
gonna win and when you're trying to
figure out which team is going to win
it's often the case that you've never
seen these teams play each other before
or you have seen them play each other
before but you think that you can do a
better job than just like counting how
many times previously you know Ohio
State the Michigan State or whatever so
what we want to do is we want to
estimate the team ability based on the
match outcome and we are going to use a
linear model to model team ability and
it's going to have group and individual
level characteristics so another multi
level model same thing a little bit more
complicated and what we're interested in
is when we've got a soccer match we're
not going to model it in terms of just
two one and who lost
we're going to model it in terms of the
scored
Frenship differential so if if germany
scores three goals and nigeria score
scores two goals then the score
differential is one in favor of germany
and so on and so forth and what we're
looking at here is the visualization we
get to in the end of the model which is
that we're going to estimate our
uncertainty by using replication and
this is called posterior predictive
check so at the end of each what we'll
see it when we get to it our data our
data our xlviii matches up through the
quarterfinals of the Women's World Cup
there were twenty four teams and
everybody had played some amount of the
other teams but not all of them and we
have the date the match list the teams
and the scores we also need to put a
prior we don't know very much about our
teams so we're going to bring in prior
information which is just a single
number called the soccer power index
which is on this blog by nate silver mr.
538 five yeah five to thirty eight he
explains what the soccer power index is
so according to the soccer power index
the US was heavily favored u.s. women's
team and then there were going down to
you know thirty seven so it was a scale
out of a hundred points and what we do
in our stand program again just
reviewing what a stand program looks
like you you set up your your data and
we're going to take in I is going to be
the number of teams and we have a per
team soccer power index and then we have
n
matches and what we're doing is this is
you know four parallel arrays that are
essentially a row of a database table or
something like that what you see here is
that you can put bounds on your strongly
typed variables and statements are
executed in orders so you have to
declare I before you use it but you can
you know do that nicely in the
transformed data so this is a new data
block the transformed data block is
executed once when the model is
instantiated this is where you can do
work that's only going to be done once
so you can do it sloppily in an
expensive way where you're gonna it but
it allows you critically to take your
data in the way that it comes in from
the wild and then transform it on the
inside of your stand program so that you
don't ever have to worry about
munching your data in the wrong way and
then somehow the model doesn't work with
the next data set so you're going to be
always treating your data the same way
which is really super nice and what
we're doing here is we're standardizing
our soccer power index ratings so that
everything is centered on zero and you
have a variance of one so this is this
is you're familiar this is sort of
you're putting your standard your your
soccer power index on the Z scale so
we're calling it the SPI standard and
this is just Stan as a programming
language has four loops and super
powerful cool indexing found a really
really really rich library of built-in
statistical functions and every
distribution you want.we somebody has
probably implemented it and they've
probably implemented a vectorized
version of it too okay and the
parameters on our model are the the per
team random of
sex you can see that it's per team
because it's got like a vector that's
the length of the number of teams and
you can see that this is group level
because it's just a scalar so these are
the two components of our linear
regression model for the team ability
the yeah and in the transfer and we put
variance terms on the per team variation
so we've got a random effect that random
effect has both the the mean and the
variance here and we have overall
overall noise in our estimate and with
the transformed parameters block is done
at every step of the sampler and it
takes the current estimates of the
parameters and then it runs this
calculation and that's what you use at
the point when you're actually fitting
the model so here the ability is not a
parameter it's a quantity that we have
to use when we're calculating the other
parameters in the model so by virtue of
having this transformed parameter
ability when we compute with the ability
we will be making the proper inferences
about all of the parameters in the model
and we always put priors on our
parameters and here we're putting priors
that are that are fairly fairly weak
priors
oh sorry these are pretty minimal and
somewhere out at the end I do or did I
put it in one of the previous slides
there's there's a link in here to our
prior choice recommendations but that's
an excellent question
these are the current thinking that
basically these are weekly informative
prior saying that we expect things to be
centered at zero with a certain amount
of variance model would have a well the
model might have a really hard time
fitting the Diagnostics might not be
good but this is where you are your
model checking would come in but also
your priors reflect what you know about
the world so you should be it's a
question you have to answer but the
stand forums her good place to get
advice and as I say we've got the wiki
page because this there's like tons of
tons of questions around exactly that
issue yeah so yeah so in the generated
quantities block which we haven't seen
yet but we're going to we're going to
replicate our data so now we're going to
produce a sample where at every every
for every estimate of a parameter so for
every draw from the posterior we're
going to use that draw from the
posterior and we're going to run it
through the data generating process
again using the random number generator
to push our uncertainty through to see
what we would get for data if this was
the true parameter everybody follow or
did I can yeah great so that's what
we're doing here
we're using replication and this is
going to give us a handle on our
uncertainty that we can use to draw
those credible interval lines in our our
visualization we could also in our
generated quantities block set things up
to do prediction which is really what we
want to be doing if we were doing
prediction using this model and this
regime what we would need to be doing is
we would need to be do feeding the data
that we want to make predictions about
into the model along with the data that
we're using to actually estimate the
parameters so we would actually have to
in our data block add the indices of the
teams that are going to be in the
semi-finals so there's going to be two
semifinals so we've got two teams and we
have to get all the indexes lined up
properly but then in the generated
quantities black we're going to look at
for the two semifinals we're going to
look at each semifinal game match and
we're just going to say oh okay
I've for these teams now let's just draw
from a normal and shouldn't that be
normal orangey yeah that should be
normal orangey yeah so yeah oh no
actually maybe it is maybe that would
work anyway let's do the ipython
notebook and so yeah so this is the
second notebook Oh
this notebook right okay so yeah
everything I've said is true we don't
have a lot of data and we have different
players on each team and we do have some
player data so the soccer power index is
going to be a really huge crutch here in
terms of really big prior not a lot of
data and this is the World Cup data that
we've already seen in the slides and
we'll just get it all loaded up and this
is the soccer power index where you see
that these are the top and the bottom
countries in terms of their things and
Stan code and the model is taking some
amount of time to compile so this is the
full program everything lined up and
we've seen all of these things in the
slides in this program we're not
actually doing any prediction so our
inputs are just on the we're just we're
just looking at the quarter-final
information and we haven't asked
ourselves who's going to be in the
semifinals or the final so this is just
the model that does replication and so
yeah so let us fit that and this time I
actually assembled the dictionary that
you want as an on disk file and we will
just run that model and let it fit and
whoa there we go and all of the things
in the model so we have 20
four so all of the variables in the
model now in the parameters transform
parameters and generated quantities
block we have we have a vector alpha we
have alpha beta Sigma Alpha and Sigma Y
so we're going to get all of those guys
in our sample we're also getting the
ability which is what we really care
about and we are also getting a vector
of length 48 for the 48 matches which is
the estimate using all of the team
estimated abilities we're getting an
estimate of what the range of possible
score differentials we could have seen
for that matches so when we look at the
outputs these guys are all here and and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take those things and we're going to
have to do some post-processing to get
the visualizations that we want so first
of all we care about what our estimates
of team abilities are and we think that
this is the team ability expressed as
the the expected number of goals that
they're going to be scoring in a match
because remember when we have a match
outcome we have the difference in
ability between team one and Team two
and that's the map match outcome so what
these numbers are saying is that the
u.s. is probably going to score one
point six four goals and Spain is
probably going to be outscored by a
certain amount and South Korea is really
not going to do well which is surprising
because their soccer power index rating
put them in the middle of the pack so
the data and the prior don't really lie
and the model is actually overriding the
prior and putting South Korea and I
apologize to all the South Koreans I
know they didn't do well I'm sorry and
now we're going to use the posterior
predictive check to to look at the
replicates of the matches
so this replicate is this replicate is
showing you the central confidence
interval for if we redid match number
one if we redid match number one what do
we think the score differential would it
be and what we see here is like a super
super wide super wide range of possible
outcomes we are not really very
confident about anything which is kind
of appropriate for the situation but you
know in in this in in match number one
it could have gone that you know the the
team number two could have won by as
much as a goal now probably not actually
it could have been a draw or team number
one could have been up by two or three
goals or they could have been up by as
much as five or six goals we really
don't know and so then finally what
we're going to do here is we're going to
plot the plot the make that chart that I
showed you and oh wait no first we're
going to yeah this is just a better
visualization of what I showed you up
above so in France versus South Korea it
could have been a draw in Germany versus
China it was you know definitely Germany
was going to win but still this is a
very wide range of you
information in our posterior so we're
not really very certain of anything
which is exactly what we want to know
this is why we want to be Bayesian and
we want to get this posterior
probability distribution because here we
know anything can happen and isn't that
great so now finally we're going to
crunch it all together and we're going
to create this beautiful visualization
and I really need to thank Nietzsche and
all the pie ladies who put things
together for me on this one what we're
seeing here is the black the red dot is
the actual outcome so if you let your ID
drift down this chart the red dots
should actually be on whole numbers the
black dots are just the midpoint of our
estimate and the full line is our 5 to
95% confidence
so as I'm saying this model is not a
great model there's not a lot of data
but it's a model that's comprehensible
questions
okay well in that case we can go to the
final part of this talk and I've
actually got enough time for what is
this talk over 4:30 okay great perfect
exactly the right amount of time because
I'm not going into much detail on this
last one this is this is getting again
to what cam was talking about when we
want to evaluate our models and evaluate
our inferences so this is sort of like
this is your standard machine learning
setup you've got your model you want to
publish a paper in NURBS or jml R or
whatever and you're going to take your
model and your you want a Kangol
competition you're going to take your
model you divide it up into your
training data and your test data you use
training to infer the model parameters
you plug your inferred parameters into
your data generating model
you used your tend and then you get your
test data inputs to get your test data
outputs and then you compare your test
data outputs to your gold standard and
did you do really well and isn't that
great this is a case study that's sort
of in progress Bob carpenter put this
together in April and it's showing you
why people say you should be Bayesian
this is basically going through all of
the math and all of the mechanics and
making it really super clear how
evaluation works what your loss function
is and why in the end at the end of the
day you really if you care if it's very
very important to get exactly the right
answer you really need to invest the the
time
in running a bayesian regime to get the
full posterior probability distribution
which is not always necessary I there
are plenty of times when getting a point
estimate is okay and in this case study
what he does is he sets up a logistic
regression model so logistic regression
model is your outputs your observed data
is a simple binary indicator yes/no
heads tails zero one lived I bought
didn't buy these are these are the kinds
of outcomes that you're making decisions
on and you're trying to figure out what
all of the parameters that led up to
this outcome are so it's a logistic
regression because it takes things from
a binary output and puts them on a
continuous scale so that you can
actually reason about probabilities in
this logistic regression there are 50 I
think 50 predictors and there's a
certain amount of correlation between
the 50 predictors so what we do is we
simulate data so we have known values
for all the parameters plug the known
values into the parameters use our
random number generator to generate that
random sample from the model and then
we're going to test on the model using
we're going to use different inference
regimes to fit the simulated data and
then we're going to check how well does
the simulated data match the way we're
going to check how well did our
estimates do in terms of evaluating the
test data on different metrics of log
loss and squared error
and the takeaway message is that we can
always get a lower error rate if we've
got the full Bayesian posterior that's
it's a nice case study it shows you how
to set up the evaluations and how to
recover the parameters and I didn't go
into more detail because I didn't think
that we were gonna have time to do it
but I want you to know that this is out
there and this is really your your
homework assignment from this talk and
from everything I've told you I hope
that you want to go through and work
through this yourself and I want you to
know that you could use commands 10 pi
to do this whole exercise so in Stan as
an inference engine Stan doesn't just do
Bayesian inference Stan also has
optimization routines so you can do a
maximum likelihood estimate and we have
a highly experimental kids really don't
do this and please if you hurt yourself
don't blame us experimental variational
Bayes inference it's it is what it is a
variational base is trying to take your
posterior distribution and find another
distribution that's perhaps
computationally tractable and easier to
compute and it's going to get as close
to what the real unknown posterior
distribution is with the simpler
approximation but then you have a
simpler approximation it's a real
probability distribution so you use the
mean but a point estimate of the mean of
this estimated distribution to be the
mean of your unknown distribution
maximum a-posteriori which is maximum
likelihood penalized maximum likelihood
estimates this is what you're getting
out of just about all of the
scikit-learn
it's the stay
way of computing computing the mode
essentially of your posterior
distribution and if you've got enough
data and your model is or your
distribution is well-behaved enough in
the limit the mean and the motor the
same thing and that's really super great
so maximum likelihood estimation is a
fair way to go what you don't get with a
point estimate however is the standard
deviation you don't know your
uncertainty and that is why when you do
have the full Bayesian posterior
distribution and you know both your your
location your mean and the scale of the
variance you're going to be doing a
better job at the end of the day so that
is my talk questions oh and let's go to
thanks well thank you thank you PI
ladies thank you women and machine
learning thank you team Stan and here
are a whole bunch of references that
should answer all your questions about
using students okay no let's hear some
questions yes hi Stan is just released
up to stand 2.19 and pi stand by the way
is GPL it is not BSD licensed but PI
stan has a richer set of features in
terms of working in python and getting
your data in python so commenced in if
you if you use PI stand and like pi
stand please please continue pi stan is
there trying to go to something
different but the GPL thing was actually
a big deal for a lot of our users the
reason that command stan pi is in
existence is
a really nice guy and in the university
in Marseille put together the first
version of the package which he called
Pike man Stan and I basically took Pike
man Stan and it's now been completely
rewritten but it was definitely
something that needed to be done because
everybody was writing their own
lightweight wrappers to avoid the GPL
problem yeah and but the other thing is
really that we want to be able to keep
up with the stan releases transparently
so it's that's a software engineering
problem you really you really need to
make your components as as loosely
coupled as possible otherwise you've
just got a maintenance nightmare more
questions yes you have to know your data
you have to know your data and you have
to know your application you would that
status is a tool and yeah
I mean if you could if you could do the
simplest possible model I think you know
Occam's razor says always go for the
simplest the decisions that would affect
that would be how expensive is your data
to collect and you know whatever's going
to be fastest and cheapest is probably
the answer but yeah
yes and there is there's a whole set of
package there's this in again these are
packages that exist mostly in the our
ecosystem for model checking and model
comparison so there's a package called
blue which is leave one out
l oo leave one out validation and yes
the the statisticians do have all of
these one number descriptions of how
well the model fits the data that's the
AIC or the W AIC are the D IC so you
would use the the packages and I think
rviz has some of this cooked into it to
get your actual evaluation of how well
the model fits the data but yeah they're
there there's a whole workflow that this
is embedded in and we're definitely
trying to put it all together
so that people can just sit down and
know that these are the steps that you
have to do check them off the list you
know that you're doing good science
questions
it's been a long day huh
okay thank you very much
[Applause]